>> John Haskell: At the
Kluge Center and we're glad
to have you here
[inaudible] members' room here
in the Jefferson Building.
Some of you may not know too
much about the Kluge Center,
but the Kluge Center was founded
in 2000 and its mission is
to bridge the gap
between scholarship
on the hand and congress,
other policymakers, and the
interest of public on the other
to contribute to the debate
about the challenges facing
democracies in the 21st century.
We do that in a variety of ways,
including events like this.
And let me just outline what
we're going to do today.
There will be a book
signing afterwards.
I hope you will stay around
for the reception as well.
And, basically, I'm going to
pitch some questions at John
and see what he has to say
about for 40 minutes or so,
and then we'll turn
to your questions.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Okay,
how about before [inaudible] I
just make a general statement.
So, hello, everyone.
I'm John Haidt.
I'm a professor at NYU Stern.
And we'll be talking about,
in part about my book,
The Coddling of the
American Mind.
But a lot of my research
is, we'll be talking
about some things that could
offend you or drive you crazy
if you're in that
normal reactive mode,
but I hope this beautiful
setting,
this library, will put
us all in the mode like,
we've got problems,
let's think about them,
let's talk about them, and
that's what we're here to do.
>> John Haskell:
Yeah, you know, John,
mentioned that he got
his bachelor's degree,
it was in philosophy at Yale,
a Ph.D. It was in psychology
at the University
of Pennsylvania.
And he went on to teach for 16
years at UVA before he ended
up at the Stern School
of Business and the chair
for ethical leadership at NYU.
I want to particularly emphasize
an earlier book he wrote,
because we're going to
build a question on that.
The first question I
have is built on that.
It's, I think I would say,
his most acclaimed book.
That still remains to be seen.
Let's see what happens with
the -- with the new book,
The Coddling of the
American Mind.
But it was a New York
Times bestseller.
It's called The Righteous Mind,
Why Good People Are Divided
by Politics and Religion.
I think if you want
to understand our political
divisions, in my opinion,
it's the single book
you should read.
In that book he offers
an account of the origins
of the human moral sense
and he shows how variations
in moral intuitions can help
explain the polarization
and what some might call
dysfunction of our politics.
So, a good place to start,
particularly here in Washington
for this particular
audience, is with that book.
Can you tell us about your
research related to the book
and how you got from
The Righteous Mind
to the coddled mind?
>> Jonathan Haidt:
Coddled mind, right.
>> John Haskell: And the
new book is The Coddling
of the American Mind.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Sure.
So, I study morality.
That's what I've done
since graduate school,
and I look at it both from
an evolutionary perspective
and cultural psychological,
or anthropological,
perspective at the same time.
And I was looking at how
cultures vary around the world
and why there are a lot of
similarities and differences.
And in the 1990's
I began to notice
that the American culture was
heating up to such an extent
that left and right were
like different countries,
like different cultures.
We have different
American history.
If you ask, what's
American history on the left
and the right, it's like
different countries.
If you ask, what's
the U.S. Constitution,
two different Constitutions.
You ask about climate science,
if you ask about so many things,
we're coming apart --
we were coming apart,
and that was in the 90's.
So, I began studying about, and
originally I was on the left.
I was always on the
left when I was younger,
and I began really studying
political psychology in order
to help the Democrats
win, because after 2000
and 2004 I thought, they have no
clue how to talk about morality.
I'd like to help them connect
with American morality.
So, I set out to understand the
conservatives read conservative
writings and watch
conservative TV shows,
and what I discovered was
that on any complicated issue
you want to think about,
if you're not -- if
you're only looking
at one perspective you can't
possibly understand it.
And I found it was so much
fun and so interesting to look
at things from a
conservative perspective
and libertarian perspective.
And so, eventually, I just sort
of stepped out and I said, okay,
I'm not on any team anymore.
And I think to be a social
scientist it's very helpful
to not be on a team.
It's really corrupting
to be on a team
and to want certain results
to come out of your research.
So, I was working on the problem
of political polarization
for a long time.
I wrote the book
The Righteous Mind.
It came out in 2012 and then
things kept getting worse
and worse.
But the basic perspective
that we are tribal creatures,
we evolved for tribal conflict,
we're very good at doing us
versus them, and
this is the nature --
this allows us to do sports.
This allows us to do politics.
It's all the same psychology.
So, while I'm working
on this problem,
suddenly these strange
things start happening
in my backyard, namely
universities.
Beginning in 2014 we started
seeing students asking
for trigger warnings, protesting
speakers on the grounds
that if this speaker comes to
campus it will be traumatizing
or damaging to some students.
You know, you might say, well,
why don't you just say
not go to the talk?
But, no. They would say, no, no,
we can't have this person
step foot on our campus.
So, it was a new
morality, a new fearfulness
about words and ideas.
So, Greg Lukianoff
and I wrote this book.
Greg Lukianoff came to me, he's
the president of the Foundation
for Individual Rights in
Education, he came to me
with this idea that somehow
students were learning
to interpret words and books
and ideas using the exact
same cognitive distortions
that he had learned not to do
when he learned cognitive
behavioral therapy.
He had a suicidal
depression in 2007.
He thinks cognitive
therapy saved his life.
You learn all these distortions,
black-and-white thinking,
catastrophizing, mind-reading,
labeling, all these things
that people sometimes
do, but depressed
and anxious people
do constantly.
And, so, the therapist,
you stop --
you learn how to
stop doing that.
And Greg noticed students
are beginning to really do
that a lot, catastrophizing,
everything is good or evil.
Around 2014 we wrote an
article in The Atlantic,
it comes out in 2015,
and we think we're done,
we did our analysis
of these trends.
And then, at Halloween of
2015, some of you know,
some of you don't, but at
Halloween of 2015 at Yale,
and then it went everywhere,
it went many other places,
there were giant protests.
It like a new moral culture
had emerged on some campuses,
and it's a real puzzle, and
it's a very difficult one
to work with, as we'll to,
but it's a callout culture.
It makes it very difficult
for people to work together.
So, that's how we
got from my work
on originally cultural
differences
to political differences
and the culture war
to what's going on campus.
And I think during our
discussion we'll come then off
of campus back to politics.
>> John Haskell: Yeah, we'll get
-- but sticking with campus is,
go into more detail about what
you identify as the issues
on campus and, in particular,
maybe a couple of
specific examples.
I mean, some of them have gotten
a lot of press nationally.
You know, when I was
reading your book I noticed
that you also brought in
examples that I hadn't heard
of before that were --
that were illuminating.
So, I'll --
>> Jonathan Haidt: Sure,
so, let me first check.
How many of you, if I just
ask you about the protests
at Berkeley when Milo
Yiannopoulos was scheduled
to speak?
Raise your hand if
you know what that is,
if you heard about that?
Okay, most, but not all of
you, the great majority of you.
Or, the protests at Yale
when Nicholas Christakis
was surrounded by students
who demanded he apologize,
raise your hand
if you know what that is?
Okay, there's less than half.
All right, so there are these --
the most spectacular events are
mobbing where students circle
around a professor, a speaker,
and they demand that he be fired
or he retract something.
Speaker shutdowns
where typically a conservative
speaker is invited to campus
and the students demand
that he be disinvited.
And if the president
of the university
won't disinvited them,
then they protest.
They try to block people
from coming in, or they go
and they try to shout him down.
So, these things happen.
There were some of
these in the 60's,
but that didn't happen
for a long time.
And then there's a lot now.
By a lot I mean a few dozen.
It's not happening
at every school,
but there are dozens of these.
These are always videotaped.
Everybody pulls out
their cellphone and, so,
they're on the Internet,
and especially right-wing
media sites love them
because they really show
students being intolerant
of conservative ideas
and speakers.
Those are the most
spectacular things,
but those are fairly rare.
What I'd rather talk
about with you,
or what you may not know about,
is the really subtle ways
that the speech climate
on campus has changed,
and this is very
widespread and very damaging.
So, I'll just share with
you a couple of examples,
because now people --
you know, people write
to me all the time now
with these examples.
And so one -- so, I co-run a
group called Heterodox Academy,
and the woman who now
runs it was a professor
at Harvey Mudd College,
at one of the Claremont
colleges in California.
And she uses the example of how
a student came to talk to her --
well, a student came to talk
to her and he started to say,
you know, yeah, that's
a great idea,
because that would
kill two birds with,
and he covered his mouth.
And she said, what?
Were you going to say,
two birds with one stone?
And he said, well, yes,
but that would be violent.
And he was afraid,
because if you say --
like, he could be called out,
like he could be
shamed for saying that.
There's another story from
another college in California.
Three students, this was
e-mailed to me by a friend,
her daughter and two other
people were walking on campus
and her daughter said,
wow, I'm starving,
and her friends called
her out on that.
That's insensitive,
because there are people
who are really starting.
So, those are just two
examples from college.
But this sort of thing is
happening all the time, that is,
students get prestige by showing
that they are more sensitive
to various victim groups
or marginalized groups.
They get prestige by calling
out someone for insensitivity.
Now, most students
are perfectly normal
and sane are not doing this,
but in any group there
are some who are.
And, so, if you can imagine
what it's like to be a student
where you never know when you're
going to be publicly shamed.
And, of course, someone
could not tell you
that you're being shamed,
they just go and they put it
on social media, and now
your reputation is destroyed.
This sort of thing happens
at universities all the time.
Now, it's creeping out
into the workplace.
So, this is not just on campus.
So, a woman who runs an
organization on business ethics
that I -- that I
cofounded, she said a friend
of hers was just reported to HR.
Why? Because she was
on a conference call,
and after the conference call
the person they were talking
to had been speaking so quickly
she said, wow, that guy sounded
like he was on Ritalin, and
a few days later she's called
into HR because that
was insensitive,
insensitive to people
who have ADHD.
Now, again, you can -- you can
discuss whether we should talk
about this, but this is the
pattern, is you report someone.
You don't -- you don't tend
to resolve it directly.
You report someone.
And, so, here's a review
of my book on Amazon.
Quote, I couldn't
understand why my new, bright,
young workers kept running to HR
for every little interpersonal
problem and why they refused
to show up to meetings
with the person
who they thought offended them,
because it's very threatening.
If someone tells a joke
and you're offended,
and you report them to
HR for having told a joke
to someone else, not even to
you, just you overheard it,
you're offended, it
would very frightening
and traumatizing
even, to have to be
in a room with that person.
So, you just want
to report it to HR,
have them punish the person,
and leave you out of it.
Now, imagine what it
would be like to work
with people like this.
Again, most students,
most students are fine,
but some have adopted
this new morality.
Let me make clear, this
is not the millennials.
Millennials are okay.
This is the generation
after millennials.
You see this in students
born in 1995 and after.
So, that's the phenomena
we're talking about.
>> John Haskell: You know,
and that one hits you
with a [inaudible], because you
mentioned something a couple
minutes ago about how
you saw this happening.
This is all over the
book, where, hey,
there's this dividing line.
And, you know, it's
not a bright line.
>> Jonathan Haidt:
It's pretty bright.
>> John Haskell: Okay,
then it is a bright line.
>> Jonathan Haidt:
It's a bright line.
It's amazingly bright.
>> John Haskell: In 2014.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
>> John Haskell: I'm going
to hit you with a series
of questions about that.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Okay.
>> John Haskell: And
you can come back at me
if you don't remember them all.
You know, maybe you'll
have mnemonic device to --
>> Jonathan Haidt: Okay.
>> John Haskell: But, so, why --
what's this dividing
line about in 2014?
Why is it 2014?
Was it something in 2014?
Are the roots further back?
Is it worse at some
types of colleges
and universities than others?
And I noted that you went
into great detail in the book,
in what might be as fascinating
a part of it as anything,
about how it's worse for
women, girls and then women,
than it is for boys and then
men, which is quite interesting.
So, maybe you can go
into some of the --
>> Jonathan Haidt: Sure.
So, here's the -- so, there
are only two places in history,
in modern history, where
there's a clear dividing line.
So, in 1946 is one.
If you were born in 1946
your childhood was different
than if you were born in 1943,
because there was a, you know,
everything changed
after the war.
And, strangely, if you were
born in 1995, or afterwards,
your child is different than if
you were born in 1992 or before.
And, so, and the clearest
evidence of that is contained
in the book iGen by Jean Twenge.
She goes through all kinds
of nationally representative
studies
about behavior of adolescents.
And what you find is that
beginning with kids born
around 1994, five,
they go out a lot less.
They don't -- they're much
less likely to drink alcohol,
much less likely to go out
on dates, much less likely
to have ever worked for money.
They are much more anxious,
much more depressed.
Their lives changed.
Their childhood changed.
Now, why? So, they were
hit with a number of things
that are different from the
millennials, the most important
of which is Facebook opens
up in 2006 to the world.
So, you can be a 13-year-old,
or an 11-year-old who lies,
you can be a 13-year-old in 2006
and you can get Facebook,
but very few do.
In 2007 when these kids are 11
or 12, the iPhone comes out,
and now you can have
Facebook and social media
with you all the
time, but very few do.
It's quite expensive.
But, gradually, by that
2009, a lot of them do.
So, there's huge adoption
of social media around 2009,
2010 by adolescents
in the United States.
And right at 2011,
2012 the anxiety
and depression rates start
going steadily upwards,
especially for girls.
So, social media is thought
to be the main culprit
for why things got so
bad after 2011, 2012.
If you were a millennial and
you got Facebook in college,
your brain was already
mostly formed.
But if you're 13 when you
get Facebook, Instagram,
all those things, the nature
of social relationships is
so different and so much social
comparison and fear of shame
that your sociality
is different.
So, social media is thought
to be the main thing.
But the other big thing is
the change in whether you got
to be independent
between ages eight and 12.
This is turning -- I'm
just discovering this now,
and let me do [inaudible]
with you.
So, most of you here are --
the great majority
of you are over 40.
What I want to ask you
is, how old were you
when you were allowed outside on
your own, meaning you could walk
to a friend's house
three blocks away?
You could go down to the corner
store and buy a candy bar,
or go get some milk to
bring home for your --
you know, for the family?
How old were?
Was it first grade, second
grade, third grade, sixth grade?
You know, how old were you
when you were allowed out?
First grade is usually
about, you know, six.
So, fifth grade is
like around age 10.
Think of your number
and then I'm just going
to have you call it out.
Okay, those of you over 40,
just call out the numbers.
What age?
>> Seven.
>> Eight.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Okay,
this is what I always find,
it's six, seven, or eight.
This is what it always was,
and this is what it
is around the world.
I've studied street
kids all over the world.
Street kids start
age seven or eight.
A five-year-old cannot
live out on the street.
A bunch of eight-year-olds can
run from the cops, steal food,
and sleep under a bridge, okay?
And most of you did something
like that, like not that bad,
but, you know, you
had adventures, okay?
Now, is there anybody
here under 25?
I don't think so.
Anybody under 25?
Raise your hand.
>> John Haskell: We got someone.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Okay, what
age were you allowed out?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay. What?
Okay, what I find when I
speak at colleges, it's 12,
13, 14, sometimes 15, 16.
Last week I spoke at Case
Western and one woman said six.
And I said, really?
Where did you grow up?
And she said, well, the
Philippines, but when we --
then we moved here
when I was nine
and then I wasn't allowed
out until I was 14.
So, we've done this
giant experiment
where there's this period
between eight to 12,
which is the great period
of cultural exploration,
this is the period that
children's stories are about.
How many children stories do
you know that are about an eight
or nine-year-old kid, you
know, or siblings who go off
on an adventure with
their parents?
Like, I guess it happens.
There's like The Swiss
Family Robinson or something.
But it's almost always
they leave the parents
and they go off and
have adventures.
They learn how to
be independent.
And what we've done, and we did
this in the '90s, this is why,
this is why you get
the bright line,
everybody up until the '90s,
including the millennials,
got the chance to practice
independence before it was too
late, before the window closed.
Eight to 14 is a critical --
13, critical period for cultural
learning and accent learning.
If you're exposed to a
foreign language first
at age 14, it's too late.
You will never speak
it like a native.
So, what we've done is,
we've systematically
taken this critical period
for cultural learning,
independence learning,
and we said, no independence
for you until it's too late.
We'll wait until
the window closes,
we'll wait until the
learning period is over,
and then we'll say,
now you can go out.
And guess what?
They don't go out.
They sit on their bed with their
devices and they communicate.
So, they're still social,
but it's in the safety
of their room.
>> John Haskell: So, you've
got a concept in there
that there was going
to be anti-fragility.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Right.
>> John Haskell: And
that ties to this, right?
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
So, this is such a
powerful concept.
Raise your hand if you know
what that is, anti-fragility?
Do you know what that is?
Very few. So --
>> John Haskell:
One guy back there.
>> Jonathan Haidt: So, it's a --
it's a term coined
by Nassim Taleb,
the guy who wrote
The Black Swan.
It's a brilliant concept.
It's a clunky word, but he made
it up because there is no word
in the English language
and we need it.
So, if you think about it,
like a wine glass is fragile
and nothing good happens if you
drop a wineglass on the ground.
It's fragile.
And, so, we give our
kids plastic cups.
Toddlers get plastic cups
because those are resilient.
They don't break, but
they don't get better.
There's nothing good -- it's
like, a glass doesn't get better
if you drop it on the ground.
And what Taleb wanted
was a concept for things
that get better when you
drop them on the ground.
So, he was studying the banking
system and he predicted in 2006,
he said, this banking
system is such a mess
and it's never been tested.
It's never been tested.
Anything goes wrong, it's
going down, and he was right.
And, so, he was trying
to say, well,
what we need is something
more like the immune system.
The immune system
is anti-fragile.
If you keep your kids
safe from bacteria,
what are you doing to them?
You're just -- you're just --
you're depriving their immune
system of the chance to learn.
The immune system
is anti-fragile.
The reason why peanut allergies
are going up in this country is
because we've been
protecting kids from peanuts.
We don't give them
a chance to learn
that peanuts are not harmful,
their immune system
doesn't learn.
So, this is our point in the
book, children are anti-fragile.
They have to be -- they have
to face teasing,
insults, exclusion.
They have to go out and
get lost and get scared
and ask someone for
directions home.
My kids refuse to ask
someone for directions.
It's terrifying for them.
You know, because they
haven't had to do it.
We're trying to push them out.
Anyway, my point is, you need
a lot of negative experiences
in order to become
an independently
functioning person.
And in the name of
protecting them,
we have denied them the negative
experiences that they need.
We don't let them have those
until they're 15 or 16.
>> John Haskell: And, John,
that's a great segue to the --
to the next question
I had, which is,
you and Greg have a lot
of, I mean, there's a lot
of very specific
remedies in the book,
both in the realm of parenting.
The ones I listed just quickly
after reading the book were,
disconnecting from iPhones,
much more free play,
de-emphasizing certain
types of safety.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
>> John Haskell: Which is what
you were just referring to,
as well as at universities,
promoting viewpoint diversity
among faculty and other things.
So, let's plumb a little deeper.
I mean --
>> Jonathan Haidt:
But, wait, wait, wait.
I have a suggestion.
>> John Haskell: Yeah.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Let's --
first, let me lay out
the six causal threats,
because -- let's lay out --
>> John Haskell: Okay.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Like
the multiple causes,
and then we'll talk about
how to reverse some of those.
So, I'm a social
scientist, and that means
that I study social
problems and I just tend --
you know, we tend
-- everything --
there's never one
factor causation.
Almost anything interesting,
there's going
to be all these different
intersecting,
interacting factors.
And, so, we had this very sudden
emergence of this new morality
on campus in 2014, 2015.
It seemed to come
out of nowhere.
And Greg and I in the book, we
trace it out, we say, actually,
there's six intersecting
threats.
There's like six fuses all
came together and then they met
around 2014, 2015,
things blew up.
So, I'll just briefly
run through them.
Number one is the political
purification of the universities
at a time of increasing
political polarization.
So, professors have always
leaned left, but between 1995,
when it was just about two or
three to one left right ratio
on the faculty, to 2010,
by then it's about five
or six to one left right.
And the core areas,
English, history, philosophy,
it's more like 20 or
30 to one left right.
So, we have universities
shifting much further left
at a time when the culture
war is heating up, so left
and right really, really
hate each other more.
So, if universities are now
more clearly on one side
of the culture war, their
internal dynamics are going
to be much more about
fighting the culture war.
So, we're not free to
just explore ideas.
If a conservative speaker comes
to campus, it's not like, oh,
what does he have to say?
I'm sure he's a schmuck.
It's, what?
We can't give him a platform.
So, the rise in polarization and
political purification is one
of the big factors
of why universities
have kind of gone crazy.
Not most, but the shout downs
are almost all in the northeast
and the coastal strip
of the west coast.
That's where the violence
and the intimidation is
taking place on campus.
So, the culture war
is a big part it.
Number two, the rise in
rates of mental illness.
And, again, this is, I
mentioned this a moment ago,
the statistics are stunning.
The self-report anxiety is
going up by a factor of two
or three in adolescence.
It's not just self-report,
it's not just
that they say they're depressed.
Hospital admissions for
self-harm, for taking --
drinking poison, or cutting
yourself with a sharp object,
those show the exact same
pattern, way up for girls,
not so much up for boys, but
way up for teenage girls.
Suicide is up 25% for boys from
the first decade of this century
to the last couple years, 25%
increase in the suicide rate
for boys, which is huge.
For girls it's 70%, seven zero
percent increase in suicide
for teenage American girls.
The same thing is
happening in the UK.
So, we have a real
crisis on campus.
This is even before
they get to campus.
But now we have all these
people with depression
and anxiety coming to campus,
and some of them say they
want trigger warnings.
They want safe spaces.
They want protection.
And what university can
say, no, tough it out?
You can't say that, because
then if she commits suicide,
of course, you're
exposed to liability.
I mean, there's other
reasons, compassion,
of course, is a major reason.
But the administrators,
and this is another threat,
the administrators become
increasingly focused
on liability, not on education,
so they get defensive.
And, so, we get all these
things coming together
to change the speech culture
and the administration on campus
so that it's not
about healthy debate,
it's not about vigorous
argument,
it's not about fearless inquiry,
it's about safety in danger.
And what we're talking
about the safety danger is,
ideas, books, words.
So, my kids get this in third
grade, it's all about safety
and danger, not physical,
emotional,
and this is a terrible
thing to teach kids,
that negative emotions
mean you're in danger and;
therefore, you need protection.
So, there's all these
things coming together
so that kids born after 1995
haven't been given the chance
to practice maturity
and independence.
We've been overprotecting
them, and that's why the title
of the book is The Coddling
of the American Mind.
Coddling means overprotection.
And the subtitle is,
How Good Intentions
and Bad Ideas Are Setting
Up a Generation For Failure.
So, anyway, all those threads,
they're hard to reverse.
>> John Haskell: Okay.
So, my thinking when I read
the book, of the remedies,
which are all these, what makes
sense when you get people away
from their iPhones, universities
need to have more diversity
of viewpoints in the faculty,
let's say, but those are running
into what I describe as
category six headwinds.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Uh-huh, yeah.
>> John Haskell: I mean, it's
going against the zeitgeist,
or whatever, however
you want to describe it.
So, what are you -- what are
you trying to do about that?
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah, so,
it's true that if you look
at the six trends
that we lay out,
none of them are
easily reversible,
especially the polarization.
That, I think, is just
going to get worse
and worse in this country.
But I'm actually optimistic
that we can -- if you break --
let's break the problem down.
We have to change what
we're doing to kids.
We have to change the
way we're teaching kids,
especially in high school
before they get to college.
And then we have to change what
we're doing in universities.
I'm really optimistic that
we can change childhood
for this reason.
Parents want what's -- well,
parents want what's best
for their kids, but
that's not entirely true.
Parents really, really want
their kids to be successful,
and especially to get
into a top college.
And if that means their
kids have to be unhappier,
they're going to do it.
But now that it's becoming
clear that if you want
to prepare your kid for success
and to get into a good college,
don't make them study
-- don't schedule --
don't overschedule them, make
them study from the age of four
through 16, that's setting them
up for weakness and frailty.
Now, that it's clear
there's no evidence
that starting academic
training at age four,
five, or six does any good.
In Scandinavia and Germany they
don't start until age seven,
before then it's all about play.
That's what kids are
supposed to do, is play.
So, now that it's clear
that there's a mental
health catastrophe,
especially for girls,
now that it's clear
that early academic training at
ages four, five, six don't help
at all, now that
it's finally clear
that play is actually
what the kids need to do,
now we're in a situation where
lots of parents want to do that
but they don't know
how to start.
So, when I read about all this a
few years ago, a wonderful book,
Free Range Kids by Lenore
Skenazy, I tried to get my seven
or eight-year-old son to go
outside and go to the store,
he'd say, but people
look at me funny.
There are no other
kids out there,
and he's afraid of
getting busted.
I gave him a little
license that said, you know,
if you're thinking of arresting
me, please go read Huck Finn,
and then, you know, and
then call my father.
You know, I have
permission to be outside.
But he was shy about it.
So, it's a social
coordination problem.
So, but there are ways
to solve the problem.
So, Utah is the first state,
the only state in the country
that passed a free-range
parenting law.
They specifically said last
March, they finally passed it,
you cannot be arrested for
letting your kids outside
to play, and that clear
statement means a lot more
parents are willing to say,
okay, kids, go to the park.
So, if every state,
whatever state you're in,
call your state reps, ask them
to introduce a free-range
parenting bill.
That's the first step.
Second, if you have kids or
grandkids, there are ways
to coordinate so that all the
kids in the neighborhood know,
you meet at this playground, you
meet in this person's backyard.
Kids have to have a lot
more unsupervised time.
Unsupervised doesn't mean
nobody knows where they are,
it means no adult is watching.
No adult is going to step
in to resolve conflict.
If someone gets badly
hurt they know, okay,
we go to Mrs. Smith's house.
She's right there.
But kids have to have a lot
more time to work out conflicts.
That's preparation
for democracy.
When kids play in groups they
learn how to work things out,
how to keep the game
going by being responsive
to other people's needs.
They learn compromise.
They learn how to enforce rules
and make rules that are fair.
So, I'm actually
really optimistic.
There's so much unhappiness
with par [phonetic] --
among parents about the lack
of play, the overscheduling,
the constantly being on
devices, but, you know,
but if you just tell your
kid, you can't be on a device,
what are they going to do?
No, there's no other
kids outside.
So, we have to solve all
the problems together.
So, I'm optimistic we're going
to make progress on that.
In high schools --
>> John Haskell: Why
is it worse for girls?
Why is the mental health --
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
>> John Haskell:
Situation worse for girls?
>> Jonathan Haidt:
So, we don't know,
but the leading thought is this.
So, again, this is Jean
Twenge, T W E N G E,
who wrote this book, iGen.
So, think about it this way.
All kids love devices.
Most of us, when we were kids,
we couldn't take our
eyes off the TV screen.
Our parents said it
would rot our brains.
It turns out, TV isn't
that bad for you,
but not playing outside
is bad for you.
So, the TV itself wasn't so bad.
Social media is really
different.
If you give -- if you suddenly
let all kids, you know,
by age eight, nine, 10,
have a device, what happens?
What do the boys do?
Just call it out, those
of you who have sons.
What do your boys
do with devices?
Videogames, that's right.
They play videogames
all day long.
It turns out, videogames
aren't really bad for you.
They take you away from outdoor
play, but they're often social.
My son is playing, you
know, they're like --
they're like, you know,
they're a team trying
to kill other teams.
That's actually pretty
good for you.
What do girls do?
Girls are taking selfies,
that take a long,
long time to compose.
They have filters to make
themselves look more beautiful.
So, we're all aware that
models are not real,
that girls are exposed to models
in magazines that aren't real.
We've talked about this
for 20 or 30 years,
that girls have unreasonable
beauty standards.
Now, suddenly, their
friends, the women --
the girls around
them, are distorted
to look more beautiful, to
the point where now girls
and young women are
asking for plastic surgery
so that they can look more
like their Instagram photos.
So, girls are doing a lot
more social comparison.
Girls feel much more inadequate.
And, especially, girls'
sociality is based on who's in,
who knows whose secrets,
who is being excluded.
Girls are much more about that.
Boys are more about dominance in
sports, hierarchy, and ability.
They're more vertical.
Girls are more horizontal.
And Facebook, Instagram,
these things are incredibly
powerful ways to let girls know
that they were not included
in this fun, fun event,
which is distorted to look
really super fun, to the point
where some college girls say,
I can't make it to that party.
Can you take my phone, take
some photos, and I'll post it
to make it look like
I was there?
I mean, this is crazy stuff,
but you can imagine
how teenage girls,
it really does a number on them.
If you -- so, if you first
get this stuff when you're 18
or 19, it's not so bad.
But if you first got it when
you were 13, in other words,
if you were born in 1995 or
after, and you get this stuff
when you were 13, it's
really bad for girls.
>> John Haskell: So,
switching gears a little bit.
Well, let's stick with
that actually for a second.
What about the headwinds
in universities?
You know, because colleges, some
folks probably in this room went
to some of the more elite
places, they're more liberal.
You know, there's -- tenure
has the effect of, well,
I'm going to hire people
who think like I do.
That's supposed to be academic
freedom or something, right?
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah,
yeah, that's right.
>> John Haskell: So,
there isn't the diversity,
and then you have this group
mentality, the Durkheimian thing
that you -- that you raised.
So, how do you combat that?
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah,
so, at universities we have
to make a lot of changes.
One reason I'm optimistic
is that anybody
who is a university president
or dean or administrator,
it's always been a difficult
job, but in the last two
or three years they all
say their job is becoming
impossible, because if
there's any conflict
between any two students,
one person tells a joke,
one person makes a reference,
one person wears a piece
of clothing they
bought vacation,
that's cultural appropriation.
That's insensitive.
That's offensive.
And these things can
blow up to the point
where they can get
into the newspaper.
They never know when there
will be a group protesting,
demanding that they intervene,
demanding that they
punish someone.
It's an impossible situation.
So, university presidents
are finally ready
to exert some leadership, if
they -- if they know what to do.
The first two years were marked
by an almost complete
absence of leadership.
One reason is because
the complaints often come
from either the black
students' group,
the women students' group, the
LGBT group, and nobody wants
to stand up against them
and appear insensitive.
We're very progressive.
We're very focused on diversity
and inclusion to the extent
that a lot of these protests
are linked in some way
to an identity issue, nobody
can stand up against that.
One reason I'm optimistic
is that in the last year
so many people, so many
great people, are writing,
these are people who are
not straight white males,
are writing to say the way
we're doing identity politics is
really bad for everybody,
including my group.
So, you know, black
scholars are not uniform.
There's a lot of diversity
among them, and we're beginning
to see some, like John
McWhorter, a whole bunch,
that are now saying, wait,
this kind of identity
[inaudible] is really bad
for black students.
Amy Chua, a Chinese-American
scholar at Yale Law School,
has this great book
on political tribes.
Francis Fukuyama just came out
with a book called Identity.
So, a lot of scholars, who
are not straight white males,
are saying, this is nuts to
say let's all band together,
us versus the straight
white males,
because they are the source of
the problem and let, you know --
the us versus them thinking
that is now rising in prominence
on campus, this is
a dead-end street.
This is never going to lead
to a welcoming environment
where people feel welcome.
It's going to lead
to constant conflict.
In -- and here, we can come back
to the country at large now,
a multiethnic secular
democracy is like a contraption
that should never fly.
Political organization for our
species is almost always based
on ties of blood or soil.
You get religions like Islam
that transcend it with God.
So, either blood, soil, or God.
Those are your options.
America was an experiment.
We talk about the
American experiment.
It was an experiment.
It probably shouldn't
have worked.
But, and it almost didn't work,
but if you get everything
lined up right it can work.
Clearly, a secular liberal
in the true, you know,
philosophical sense, a secular
liberal democracy can work,
and they worked all over
Europe until recently.
Now they're not working.
What's going on?
Issues of immigration,
identity, division,
these blow things apart.
America was brilliant
in the 20th century
at forming an overarching
identity,
saying we don't care
what your blood is,
we don't care we came
from, if you believe
in the American ideals,
you're in.
America had a way of creating
a superordinate identity
that was the envy of the world.
And now, many of us think
we're going down roads
of certain forms of identity
politics that reverse that
and that turn our
diversity into a weakness.
Diversity is not
automatically a strength.
It can be, it can
also be a weakness,
and I think we're
mismanaging at universities,
they're mismanaging a lot
of European countries,
and the results could
be really devastating.
>> John Haskell: And before we
go to the questions from the --
from the audience, I have
a hard question for you
and then a really easy one.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Okay.
>> John Haskell: The easy
one you can do real quickly,
but the hard one maybe you
might need some more time.
So, the Attorney General, Jeff
Sessions, and the Secretary
of Education, Betsy DeVos,
they talk a lot about --
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
>> John Haskell:
Viewpoint diversity.
DeVos even cited
one of your lectures
in a speech quite recently.
Is this helpful to you?
>> Jonathan Haidt:
That's the easy question.
No.
>> John Haskell: That was
the hard question [laughter].
>> Jonathan Haidt: Let
me elaborate on that.
So, I found -- I cofounded a
group called Heterodox Academy.
Is anybody here a
professor in any way?
Are you listed at
the webpage of any --
okay, all of you professors,
if you're listed on the webpage
of any university, I urge you
to go to heterodoxacademy.org.
We founded it in 2015.
It's a bunch -- it's now
2300 professors who believe
that viewpoint diversity is a
good thing, that we have to seek
out and welcome political
diversity, in particular.
I'm really proud of the fact
that we're the only
politically diverse organization
in the academy that I know of.
We're about 20% professors on
the left, 20% on the right,
and we're mostly all the
people who don't fit in,
so it's libertarians, centrists,
and people who are
just really heterodox.
So, we've been advocating
for more viewpoint
diversity since 2015.
Donald Trump in his very first,
when he had that first debate,
you know, he was sort of
introduced to the country,
the very first thing he says is,
there's too much political
correctness in the country.
And we don't talk a lot
about political correctness,
but we are kind of
pushing back against it.
It was like, oh no, I
don't want him on my side.
And, Betsy DeVos is on my side
and Jeff Sessions is on my side.
And the only point
I'm making here is
that universities are
left-leaning progressive
institutions, that if you
push them from outside,
and especially Congress
has a history
of managing things terribly.
I mean, if Congress is going to
legislate how you do something,
it's going to be a disaster.
So, I don't want the
federal government saying,
universities need to --
we're going to punish those that
don't have 50% Conservatives.
I mean, this is not helpful.
This is not a good idea.
So, I think that
we can solve it.
I think we now have the will.
We now have a much
better understanding.
I think we can solve
this problem ourselves.
And if, in a time of a culture
war, if viewpoint diversity
and openness to free inquiry,
if these become things
that the Conservatives want,
then ipso facto, they're going
to be things that the
Progressives don't want.
Just as Obama Care was
a Conservative idea,
but once Obama took it on now
Conservatives were against it.
That's the nature
of a polarization cycle
and a culture war.
So, I'd really rather
they just stay out of it.
>> John Haskell: But it
actually illustrates one
of the things you talk about
in, maybe all of your books,
but certainly the two I've read,
is that just because somebody's
on the other team doesn't
mean they're always wrong,
and that's one of the, you know,
the things that you've stressed,
that's one of the -- you know,
it's a cognitive,
it's a CBT thing.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
>> John Haskell: Like, they're
not necessarily wrong all
the time.
You may disagree with Betsy
DeVos 93% of the time,
it doesn't mean she can't
stumble upon the truth every now
and then.
>> Jonathan Haidt: That's right.
>> John Haskell: So, you
want to take it seriously.
>> Jonathan Haidt:
Yeah, that's right.
So, politics is one
kind of game,
and it's analogous more to war.
Well, you know, politics
is supposed
to be a positive sum game,
but current American
politics is more like war.
University life is
nothing like that.
University life, we need
-- we need our opponents.
We need to be challenged
because we're all so subject
to the confirmation
bias, we're all so --
scientists are not just
really smart people,
and they don't make discoveries
because they're so smart,
scientists are productive
because they have an institution
in which they're put together
so that whatever they say
will be challenged by others.
And it's that challenge process
that knocks down the bad ideas,
that strips us of
our wishful thinking.
Politics isn't like that.
Politics, at its
best, can do that,
that's what a deliberative
body is supposed to be,
but they don't do that in
the Senate chambers anymore.
>> John Haskell: So, the
quick sum up, I thought,
might be useful for people is,
that you open the book talking
about the three great untruths.
And you've touched on all three
of them, but it might be good
to sort of list the three.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah, sure.
So, yeah, so, the subtitle of
the book is, How Bad Ideas --
How Good Intentions and
Bad Ideas Are Setting
Up a Generation For Failure.
Here are the three bad ideas
that the book is about.
What doesn't kill
you makes you weaker.
Always trust your feelings.
Life is a battle between
good people and evil people.
All three of these
are really bad ideas.
All three of these are the exact
opposite of ancient wisdom.
My first book, The
Happiness Hypothesis,
had 10 chapters devoted
to 10 psychological ideas,
that you find all
over the world.
Those three that I just said
are the exact opposites of three
of the chapters in
my first book.
If we can teach our kids
to believe all three,
we can almost guarantee
that they will fail in life,
and they will move back with
you after college [laughter],
and that's what we're doing.
>> John Haskell: All right,
so, let's see what kind
of questions folks might have.
Who's got the mic?
You have the mic, Travis
[assumed spelling], and --
oh, and Mike [assumed
spelling], over here.
Yeah, Mike has a mic.
So, over here first.
>> My name is [inaudible].
I teach American
politics in Tokyo.
>> Jonathan Haidt:
Oh, very good.
>> At [inaudible] University.
This is more of a
clarification than a question.
You had this political
correctness
and culture wars back
in the '90s, right?
So, what's different
this time around?
I guess, in the '90s
was top down,
and this time it's bottom up.
>> Jonathan Haidt: That's
correct, that's right.
>> Or, is it just --
>> Jonathan Haidt: Well, yeah.
So, good question.
In the 1960's there was a huge
wave of student rebellion.
[ Inaudible ]
Oh, and that's right.
So, the 1960's was [inaudible],
and there was a lot
of violence then.
I mean, you look at what
was happening on campus.
There was the Kent
State massacre.
So, there was -- it was much
more intense in the '60s.
Then there was another wave
in the late '80s, early '90s,
that was actually
more faculty driven.
That was about diversifying
the cannon, the reading list.
That sort of comes
out of humanities,
protests against they had
too many dead white males
on the syllabus.
So, and then there's the new
one which started in 2014, 2015.
So, you're right,
there's three waves.
This is not new.
What is new is the
medicalization of it.
In other words, in
the previous waves,
people said this is unjust.
This must change.
Nobody said, this
is making me sick.
This is going to
damage my friends.
We need protection from that.
Nobody said that.
That's what's new.
And, so, that's what
Greg first noticed,
was it's the medicalization,
it's the idea that
we are fragile.
We are so fragile
that we need you,
the administrators,
to protect us.
In the '60s what was different
was, the students were radical,
but first of all,
the administration
was often actually
politically conservative.
So, it wasn't -- the
whole campus wasn't
on one page politically.
So, the ideology -- there was an
ideological conflict on campus,
now there's not much
of a conflict
on campus, it's all on one side.
And then there's
the medicalization
and then there's
the social media,
which allows any little thing
can blow up within hours
to become a campus-wide
disaster.
So, those are the
three big differences
that make this situation
much, much --
well, I shouldn't say worse,
because the '60s was --
there was, again,
a lot of violence,
but makes its this
one different.
And it's what makes
this one so --
it's not like this,
but it has spread.
These issues are now
out in the workplace.
Not all industries,
but any industry
that hires creative talent
from the top universities.
So, journalism, tech, media,
the arts, I hear from people
in those industries,
their recent hires are
doing this stuff there, too.
>> John Haskell: Got
a gentleman over here.
[ Inaudible ]
Is it on?
>> Okay, thanks.
I'm wondering if you've
looked at parenting
for the age group
you're describing with --
for kids who have special needs?
I'm just wondering
to what degree --
[ Inaudible ]
>> John Haskell: So,
you're connecting what John
is talking about to kids --
>> Jonathan Haidt: Kids
with special needs?
>> John Haskell:
With special needs,
with special needs children?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Just what the effects
are for those types of kids.
>> Jonathan Haidt:
Yeah, that's a --
that's a very good question.
So, Greg, actually, I can say --
I asked him if I can say this.
Greg Lukianoff, my
co-author, has dyslexia.
Now, that's not exactly --
that's not exactly special
needs, but what you --
what you hear -- so, many
very, very successful people,
most very successful people
had major setbacks, traumas,
obstacles in childhood.
So, depending on
how it's handled,
those things could be the
thing that they overcome,
and that's part of the
anti-fragility principle.
I don't know how special-needs
kids are treated now.
I should. That's a great point.
Because if our whole point is,
since the '90s we've been
massively over protecting kids,
presumably we're doing it even
more for special needs kids.
So, it would be fascinating to
see whether special needs kids
who grew up in the
'70s or '80s ended
up being much more successful,
but those '90s are
overprotected.
I recently came across a
concept, the dignity of risk,
I think it was called.
It comes at a disability
scholarship, where when you're
in a protective role to a
person, say in a wheelchair,
with a disability, and you
make the decision for them
about what risks they can take,
you're infantilizing them,
you're denying them dignity.
And, so, some disability
rights activists say,
let us make our own choices.
Let us take some risks.
You can't make all
our decisions for us.
I think it's an important
concept
for child rearing in general.
>> John Haskell: We have
another [inaudible] here.
So, we'll have the lady here and
then the gentleman will be next.
>> Thank you.
You probably, I am going to
guess, are familiar with,
and I'm not going to get
his first name at all,
but I believe his last
name is Louv, L O U V,
who wrote a book called
Last Child in The Woods.
>> Jonathan Haidt: Oh yeah.
>> And about the way
that our relationship
to the natural world
has changed completely,
because children are not
encouraged to go out and play
in nature, or close to nature,
probably not wilderness,
and that the consequences
of that, it cuts us off
from forming profound emotional
connections with the world
in a way that we badly need if
we are going to do something
about climate change,
among other things.
>> Jonathan Haidt:
Absolutely, yes.
>> And it seems it dovetails
with what you're talking
about very nicely.
>> Jonathan Haidt:
It absolutely does.
An interesting thing about
the current phenomena
that we're writing about is
that it's happening in all
of the Anglosphere countries.
It's not happening on
continental Europe.
And one reason is that the
UK did what we did in saying,
we've got to get kids learning
math earlier and earlier,
whereas in Germany,
Switzerland, Scandinavia,
they send the kids out.
I know they do this in
Switzerland and Germany,
at four the kids are -- one of
the main activities is, okay,
we're going out into the woods,
and they might even
have a hatchet or a saw.
Let's make a fire, you
know, with five-year-olds.
And it may happen that
a kid gets burned.
That might happen.
And then guess what?
They learn.
So, there's this great
thing on Staten Island --
Governors Island in New York
called the Junkyard Playground
where I had to sign like a
huge several page release
to let my kids in, but there's
hammers and nails and lumber
and kids could get hurt.
And I watched, and
they sometimes do.
Like I watched a kid pounding
a nail and he hit his thumb,
and he didn't go
running off crying.
Just went like this, owe, and
he picked up the nail again
and he kept going
and did it again.
And by the third
time, he learned how
to -- how to pound a nail.
So, kids get experience
in nature.
Kids always have.
Because we got this crazy
idea in our heads in the '80s
that if the kid is unsupervised,
if no adult is watching,
that kid will be abducted
by a sexual predator.
That kid will be -- or,
that kid will be abducted.
We got this idea
because of cable TV.
We freaked out in the '80s.
By the '90s we stopped
letting kids out.
And the two most
dangerous places
that we would never let our
kids go are public restrooms
and the woods.
We would never let our kids
go to those two places,
because who knows what
will happen to them there,
and it's a real shame for
exactly the reasons you say.
And, so, this is one of things
I'm hopeful about, that,
you know, so many people are
recognizing like nature is good.
We have to let kids out into it.
And, so, I think if we can --
it's scary to let
your kid out alone,
but if schools start
letting them out,
if parents get together and
make an effort, I think --
I think we can reclaim
the woods.
>> John Haskell:
This fellow here.
>> Do you have any thoughts
on, what if colleges went
to a more open admissions
sort of arrangements,
what might that do to, for
example, high school kids
who now are under such pressure,
they might be able to, you know,
enjoy life a little bit more
and not have such pressure
when they're in high school,
and then when they get
to get college maybe you'd have
a more diverse, more inclusive,
more -- less inequality?
>> Jonathan Haidt: Yeah, so,
in America I think it would --
we'd never go to a totally
open admissions policy.
We do -- we are committed
in some ways to some kinds
of meritocracy, but our
meritocracy has gotten too much
test based, and that
is a problem.
We reward people for
the kind of intelligence
that does well on tests.
And then there's a wonderful
column by Ivan Krastev,
who's actually a fellow here
in the New York Times
two years ago,
about how the really twisted
thing about our meritocracy is
that we reward people for
doing well on the test,
and then they believe
they deserved it
because they did
well on the test.
So, there are problems.
And there are some
interesting proposals to say
above a certain level of
grades and test scores,
above that we do it randomly.
Those would be hard
to implement,
but those might do some good.
I would rather we
go another way.
The problem you're
trying to address is
that kids are pressured so
much to succeed, middle-class,
upper-middle-class kids
[inaudible] so much pressure,
there's no time for play.
What we suggest in the
book is that we should --
we should accept the fact
that 18-year-olds should
not be on college campuses.
Eighteen-year-olds today,
as Jean Twenge puts it,
showing the data, an 18-year-old
today is about the same
as a 15-year-old
from 30 years ago.
Eighteen-year-olds, American
18-year-olds are generally --
some of them are
certainly ready,
but a lot of them are just not
ready to be on a college campus.
And when we bring them to
college campuses, they end up --
many of them end up requesting
infantilizing procedures,
which then damages everything
else for everyone else.
What if the top schools all
say, we strongly favor people
who have taken a year or
two off, had a gap year,
done military service, lived
somewhere else in the country.
We think a red, blue switch,
like if you're from a blue area,
go get a job in a red area,
or vice versa, meet people.
We've got to get kids
away from their parents.
Now, boarding school
might seem like a way,
and I need to do
research on this,
boarding school also
infantilizes
and teaches some bad
habit, some of them.
I don't know enough to
comment on all of them.
But if colleges, if Harvard
and Yale start saying,
we're not going to
get the, you know,
the person who did 12
extracurriculars in addition
to double 800's on the
SAT, we're not going
for that person anymore.
We're going to favor military
veterans, people who went off
and did something for a
couple years, and we're going
to favor people who
are 19 or 20 years old.
That would be a better
way, I think,
to take the pressure off kids,
to make parents stop pressuring
their kids to achieve, achieve,
achieve for your resume.
>> So, we're going to wrap
up the conversation there.